the health district announcing those
over the age of 70
can now make appointments joe mueller is
live outside the soon to be mega
vaccination site at cashman center with
some important information
joe within the next few days people over
the age of 70 will start to get the
vaccine now today the health district
released some more information on the
plan moving forward including
turning cashman center here into a mega
vaccination site they hope to administer
thousands of doses a day southern nevada
is moving on to the next phase in the
fight against covet 19.
until today we have a minister in the
county
more than 29 000 vaccine doses
starting thursday people over the age of
70 will be able to get the vaccine
in addition to frontline medical workers
we know our senior population
60 to 80 is the highest capacity
in the hospitals so it's very important
we have that track
the goal is to get 40 to 45 000 a week
moving forward
a number of vaccination locations are
around the valley a mega site is set to
open this week at cashman center
our hope is that that site in the coming
weeks will be able to do
4 000 a day and then we plan on
replicating that
as necessary through the through the
valley the health district is working on
more locations such as the las vegas
convention center
the state is also working on a plan with
major pharmacy companies
pharmacies will be also offering vaccine
to the seniors so they will have that
that a possibility in the neighborhood
the state will be releasing information
about pharmacy vaccinations within a few
weeks
appointment times may be limited now but
the health district says more times will
be opening up
soon to get more protected we're looking
at doubling our capacity
in the next week or two
now officials did stress the importance
of having an appointment the health
district says you can make these
appointments on their website however
due to so many people trying to book
appointments
on the links below they are working a
little bit slow so you are encouraged to
check back
within the next few hours reporting live
here at catchment center joe mohler 8
news now